now a campaign to push for abortion to
be decriminalized is to be launched this
month by the country's newest political
party the women's equality party led by
Sophie Walker says it's time abortion
was made a sexual health and human
rights issue rather than a Victorian
criminal law where a sentence that
exists for making the decision to
terminate a pregnancy well I'm join now
from central London by the chair of
abortion rights Carrie able and in the
studio by pro-life campaigner at
Christian Concern Aisling Hubert and
Carrie cheek to you first I was
astonished actually I didn't realize
that there was a life sentence still in
law that a woman can be forced to serve
if she has an abortion I mean this is a
very old law admittedly did you think a
lot of women know that they're actually
something that's inside their bodies are
subject to criminal law and not medical
guidelines yeah I think I think that is
surprising for people and the first
thing is this law is from 1861 Queen
Victoria was on the throne when this
legislation was enacted and I think it's
really old it isn't in Scotland they
manage perfectly well without it and
what we're talking about abortion from
abortion rights point of view we've had
a position against decriminalization of
abortion ever since we we existed and
we're talking about two clauses in the
eighteen sixty-one act that I just don't
think it's relevant anymore we don't
live our lives in the same way as we did
in the 1860s let's put that to Ashley
Hugh but I mean it it's a very old law
it's a law that existed before women
even had the right to vote yeah it was a
very different time yeah why do you
think it's still appropriate that that's
something that happens inside women's
bodies is enshrined into into a law that
can lead to them going to prison for
life well when you look at the offenses
against the persons act by definition in
the title itself is to stop offences
against people and that includes the
unborn child so in that same act we
might say yes it's an old law but it
protects actually our lives from
offences against us so inherently it's
recognized that the preborn child is a
human being and therefore if it is humor
what would we expect the Lord's be when
it comes to protecting life that's a
fair point isn't it Gary lots of the
laws that we use in a bye-bye have been
set down some of them date back to Roman
times in principle just because the law
is old doesn't mean it's out of date
yeah but this lorry is out of day and
we've got the 1967 abortion act now so
abortion is legal so I don't think that
this is necessarily relevant and as I
said they don't have this law in
Scotland there's plenty other laws that
protect women for example from domestic
violence and that's what we're talking
about but this is about criminalizing
women and girls who are who are and
perhaps taking pills to take charge of
their own destiny and it's dangerous
because it puts them in worries it
worries them about trying to get medical
attention if they need to because
there's a life sentence potentially hand
over their head and also and I think
it's not able to be proved really
because if somebody's having a
miscarriage we've there's a worry that
there's a concern that they'll be
questioned and second guest and and then
potentially have a life sentence over
their head for something like a
miscarriage I mean actually it is
slightly confused in the sense that but
as Kari says you know you you can have
an abortion it's not illegal but there
is it also this element in the criminal
justice system that can prosecute a
woman the system as it stands means the
doctors need to doctors to sign off on
an abortion now that actually some
people think that the health services
are becoming a bit complicit in it as a
situation stands at the moment even
though it is in law that a woman can
have a life life sentence in prison for
doing it that's not happening in
practice so what merit is the law it's
not actually being used well I actually
totally believe what you're saying
because I'm I I myself attempted to
prosecute to doctors for green to do
gender selection abortions so literally
passing a death sentence on baby girls
in the womb simply for being girls and
the case was dropped by the CPS and I
was left with a 47 thousand pound bill
to pay
and a potential prison sentence if I
don't pay that bill for trying to
prosecute doctors who are willing to
kill little girls in the womb simply for
being girls so I'm totally for women's
rights but first and foremost their
right to life above all other rights but
but isn't it isn't a fundamental heart
of women's rights their ability to
decide what happens to their own body I
totally believe that women should be
able to decide what happens to their own
body and their lives but what about
these women's rights what about the
little babies and their wombs I think
I'll right to choose should stop when it
infringes on another person's right to
life Carrie you're frowning there and
well I think I think there's your own
confusing several different things so
the the call for decriminalization is to
take it out of the Criminal Code and to
take this life sentence away from women
so that's punishing the woman what you
were talking about is the doctors and
actually the CPS showed that the doctors
had followed the guidelines the
guidelines are to ensure that a
conversation happens between the
doctrine and the woman and so that the
decision is made I mean I don't think
that two doctors should have to make
this decision but the decision is made
based on the woman's circumstances in
her health and her mental health so I
think that trying to confuse these
things is is not helpful and it's
misleading I think that if you're
against abortion you against abortion
don't dress it up and one in three women
will have an abortion in her lifetime
and we want to make sure that abortions
are safe and legal and accessible and so
that you know normal women can choose
what they do with their bodies but I
definitely it's women are going to have
abortions I believe that being
completely deceived about the reality of
what abortion is one in three women have
at least one question you're totally
right and but if they're gonna have an
abortion let's talk about what abortion
is it's the intentional literal
decapitation dismemberment and
disembowelment of a little human being
you can look on a boat c7 coda you can
you see there are lots either fitted
yourself well it's say obviously it
either is it is that the procedure is
what it is there are lots of medical
procedures that are deep
pleasanton that nobody would wish to
look at but the fact that the matter is
it's about the woman's right to choose
whether or not she goes through with
that no woman goes into an abortion
thinking this is going to be a picnic
does she owe me I would never say sorry
it was just as yeah yeah of course I
would never say that it's an easy
decision for a woman to make it's one of
the hardest decision she is going to
have to make but let's look at why is it
hard why isn't it hard to go in and have
an operation may be to remove an
appendix which could cause harm to your
body or why they not hard decisions and
an abortion is a hot decision is it may
be because in our consciences we know
that it's actually killing an innocent
human being Carrie as you say what 13
we've been having abortion before the
age of 45 200,000 abortions in Britain
last year are you comfortable with that
figure do you think that that the number
of abortions in the UK should be lower I
don't know i mean my might if they've
been steady over the years um my point i
was going to make before about women not
knowing what they're doing um more than
fifty percent of women who have
abortions now have already got a child
so they know exactly what they're doing
they know what it takes to look after
children properly and they're making a
decision about their capacity to do that
and I think that confusing the issue
anymore and what I've learned over the
years that only a woman can decide what
happens to do to her body at that place
and time she's the only one that knows
how circumstances and I think that we
have to trust women I totally think we
should trust them and if they are given
all the information and so it's our job
to give them more than all the
information not just about the procedure
of an abortion but what actually happens
to that other little person inside their
body do you think the women are given
enough information carry that guy's been
some criticism hasn't there in the last
year of some of the organizations that
support women when they're trying to
make these decisions that perhaps they
haven't been giving them clear enough
guidance well let's talk about the
guidance that is given because when when
we've done studies about the crisis
pregnancy centers run by anti-choice
organizations they're the ones giving
misinformation they're the ones saying
that women will have them
a chance of getting breast cancer which
isn't prove scientifically that they
learned that they'll suffer depression
which isn't proved scientifically and so
I just think that you know the
information that anti-choice
organizations want to give isn't
accurate and I think what they're
concerned about is giving accurate
information really and that is what the
conversation between doctor is that you
know that's what to you know there were
two doctors involved in this and then
the clinic and there's there's loads of
opportunities for women to ask these
questions and we don't get an
overwhelming feeling from women that
they that they're not getting this
information well they're not satisfied
with their choice what they are
unsatisfied is with the access okay well
i only got two and all access we only
got time for every one more actually do
you think that by keeping abortion as a
criminal act it's actually going to
reduce the number of women that actually
have a do you think it actually achieved
anything well at the moment I'm sad to
say that are we're not enforcing the law
as it was arresting do you think you
should be enforced would you like to see
women going to prison for life rather
than a ball I would like I would like to
see the lives of all human beings
protected under the latter I going to
prison under an abortion under the Human
Rights Act which says that all of us
have the right to life so I would ask
what would we want the law to say when
it comes to human beings right to life
and how far should we go to protect
their rights to life I mean most people
don't know that at 16 days it's been
detected by heartbeats detect at 16 days
and at six weeks brain waves and most
abortions happen after that time I'm
just trying to get for you a really
clear yes I know answer though do you
think that that women should go to
prison for having an abortion
potentially for life yes or no so at the
moment most women because they don't
know but there it's a little human being
inside their body no women know when
their prac when they get pregnant that
there's a human being and so well we
have talked women that have said no the
doctor said it's a clump of cells it's
not a human being it's just a Columbus
cells but do you think yes I know women
should go to prison for having an
abortion I believe that in the future at
the moment no because it's legal in this
country but when the law if the law
became illegal if it made it completely
illegal to have abortions then we should
be protecting the lives of preborn
children in the same way we should be
protecting the lives of born children
okay so good to talk to you both Aisling
hubert from
prolife campaign Christian Concern and
also carry able from abortion rights
thank you both very much for coming in
and talking to us